[Musica]
vi piacciono i cioccolatini
anche a me
che cosa vi fanno pensare
a una pausa tra un dovere l'altro
ha una piccola dolce trasgressione un
momento di piacere
un momento di condivisione tra amici con
le persone a cui si vuole bene
a tutte queste cose insieme forse
è un libro
a che cosa vi fa pensare
a me un libro fa pensare alle stesse
cose più o meno come credo a voi ma se
andiamo a chiederlo a qualcuno dei miei
studenti come per esempio caterina di
nardò di 1ª b le risposte saranno un
pochino differenti e in genere avranno a
che fare con qualcosa che riguarda la
noi ha
un compito da svolgere un dovere ed
eseguire un momento di tedio legato allo
studio un interrogazione incombente a un
voto positivo da doversi guadagnare
più in generale l'idea di lettura per i
ragazzi è associata a qualche cosa che
in teoria bello utile e interessante ma
per cui purtroppo soffrono di una
cronica mancanza assoluta di tempo
mancanza assoluta di tempo che peraltro
non si riverbera per altre attività come
telefonino playstation computer musica e
per fortuna va detto che non tutti i
ragazzi soffrono di questa mancanza di
tempo esistono dei giovani che
appartengono a quella grande
internazionale che il circolo mondiale
dei lettori per esempio una mia lunga di
quinta alessandra vallone è l'unica da
me certificata che si è riuscita a
leggere tutto guerra e pace prima di
compiere la maggiore età e senza averne
riportato effetti collaterali sono
sono in realtà delle eccezioni
eppure e qui parlo per esperienza
personale da insegnanti oltre che da
scrittrice
sono moltissimi i ragazzi che alla
parola libro sospirano alzano gli occhi
al cielo e si piazzano una mano sulla
fronte come in presenza di un guaio
imprevisto
io ho provato veramente in tanti modi a
incentivare gli alunni alla lettura per
esempio una volta organizzato delle gare
di lettura squadre mi sembra un'idea
veramente bella idea geniale dal mio
punto di vista per i miei lunghi non so
infatti ho scoperto che erano usciti a
barare anche lì
fabio canfora mi ha infatti confessato
un giorno di essere riuscito a mettersi
d'accordo con la capo squadra avversaria
e di essersi scambiati la risposta per
ottenere un pareggio che in definitiva
andava bene per entrambe le squadre
ho assegnato del libri da leggere
durante le vacanze estive durante le
vacanze pasquali durante le vacanze
natalizie e ogni volta al rientro delle
vacanze estive
pasquali e natalizie
mi sono ritrovata con 25 relazioni tutte
identiche tra loro da bat angelo azzurro
e tutte identicamente tagliate e
incollate da amazon che dio lo punisca o
da wikipedia
e allora sono passati alle minacce o
minacciato compiti in classe e
interrogazioni a tappeto verifiche a
sorpresa con risultati abbastanza
deludenti però non mi sono persa d'animo
e così molti tentativi dopo mi sono
presentata in classe con una scatola di
cartone
po più grande di questa dentro c'erano
tante praline di cioccolato a vari gusti
e anche un libro
aperto la scatola
accesso ragazze di metterci di mettersi
in cerchio attorno a me e ho chiesto a
ciascuno di loro di estrarre
una pralina dalla scatola scartarla
mangiarla e il cambio leggere
semplicemente qualche pagina del libro
che avevo portato ad alta voce per tutti
gli altri compagni
il primo più intraprendente e più goloso
degli alunni è stato salvatore paparo su
questo non avevo idea non avevo dubbi
non per l'intraprendenza nella lettura
ma sicuramente per la golosità ha preso
la pallina l'ha mangiata è iniziato a
leggere ad alta voce e gli altri
ascoltavano via via anche gli altri sono
stati contagiati sia dalla golosità che
dal libro è così l'ora è passata le
pagine sono volate la scatola di
cioccolatini si è svuotata alla fine
dell'ora abbiamo preso la scatola
abbiamo buttata nel cestino della carta
il libro però lo abbiamo conservato e
così quando è suonata la campanella
uno dei miei alunni francesco fusco ha
detto ma come prof e già finita
e non si riferiva solamente alla scatola
di cioccolatini ma anche allora di
lezione
non gli era mai capitato che un'ora di
lezione passasse in maniera così veloce
che trascorresse così spensierate era
incredulo e così abbiamo deciso di darci
appuntamento alla settimana successiva
con lo stesso libro ormai si erano
appassionati alla storia e con qualche
altro dolcetto aldo annichiarico alzato
la mano e ha detto prof prof
mio padre fa i muffin al cioccolato più
buoni del mondo li porto io
applauso della classe e mio ed è nata
così la nostra ora di lettura uno spazio
libero in cui ragazzi potessero leggere
a turno ad alta voce dallo stesso libro
ognuno con la sua copia senza l'obbligo
della verifica senza l'obbligo di
compilare delle schede senza l'obbligo
di barrare caselle con crocette e
soprattutto senza l'obbligo di redigere
le terribili analisi del testo che tanto
deprimono la fantasia dei nostri ragazzi
d'altra parte lo diceva gianni rodari
il verbo leggere è l'unico che non
tollera in modo imperativo non si può
costringere qualcuno a leggere per un
fine in particolare che non sia quello
del piacere della lettura
i ragazzi avevano preso l'abitudine di
aspettarmi in classe già seduti a
cerchio ognuno con la sua copia del
libro i dolcetti già predisposti e
preparati da genitori compiacenti
sì perché all'inizio questa attività
dell'ora di lettura
fu vissuta come un'attività clandestina
carbonara un po come la setta dei poeti
estinti di quel bellissimo film con
robin williams ecco come facevamo
proprio così non avevo inserito questa
attività in nessuna delle programmazioni
scolastiche non era stata presentata
alla preside non era nel piano del
miglioramento nel lab nel mar del pin
del po nel ping nel punk che queste
sigle terribili che deprimono la nostra
attività di insegnanti quotidianamenti
anche questo ha il suo fascino
cioè sembrava di fare qualcosa di
proibito qualcosa che ci scoprivano fila
valori e libri in mano e ce li facevo
rimettere in cartella leggiamo di
nascosto in clandestinità come dei
carbonari ebbene in questo modo alla
fine di un solo anno
un'ora alla settimana siamo riusciti a
leggere tutto il giovane holden tutta
l'isola di arturo e molti dei racconti
di hemingway e ci siamo spazzolati anche
diversi ciambelloni sia dolci che salate
negli anni successivi e fino a oggi ho
continuato a proporre l'ora di lettura
in tutte le mie classi con lo stesso
metodo e con gli stessi risultati
il risultato è che i ragazzi leggevano
davvero d'altra parte lo facevano
davanti ai miei occhi si appassionavano
davvero gioivano davvero e soprattutto
imparavano ad associare il momento della
lettura con un momento del piacere
momento della condivisione della
convivialità un'esperienza che non era
legata a qualcosa che doveva dare in
cambio
un'interrogazione è una scheda
no era tutto gratuito perché la lettura
è gratis lo facevano per questo
naturalmente anche per saltare in una
interrogazione di compiti e per i
dolcetti
però quel piacere rimaneva incollato
alle pagine del libro si creava una
connessione forte ma sotterranea tra
momento della lettura
il momento del sollievo della pausa
della gioia del buon cibo una specie di
connessione pablo piana in verità la
lettura e cioccolato
ho immaginato infatti che associando uno
stimolo positivo alla lezione alla
lettura questa potesse rimanere poi come
un'attività a cui guardare con sollievo
invece che con preoccupazione un po come
il cane dello scienziato russo pavlov
che al suono della campanella
e cominciava a salivare per che
presagiva l'arrivo della pappa e in
effetti poi a pensarci bene l'idea che
arturo de rosa un mio alunno di seconda
passando davanti a una libreria invece
di cambiare marciapiede iniziassi a
salivare come davanti alla pasticceria
non era poi tanto male
una specie di cura di ludovico di
arancia meccanica però al contrario
d'altra parte è la stessa cosa che
succede anche a noi quando passiamo
davanti alla vetrina di una libreria
oppure quando guardiamo i libri dallo
schermo del telefonino dal computer che
a noi fanno gola quei libri e vediamo
proprio come tante praline di cioccolato
ognuno nella sua carta diversa che la
copertina ognuna col suo gusto
particolare che sono la trama i
personaggi la storia ognuno col suo
aroma
addirittura annusiamo stesso è una cosa
che facciamo tutti annusare il libro
ogni libro ha un suo odore diverso e poi
alcuni sono protetti dal cellophane
addirittura per conservare meglio alla
roma e quindi quando andiamo a casa la
prima cosa è strappare il cellophane e
annusare equilibri
dentro ogni libro diverso al suo sapore
la sua voce la voce soprattutto la voce
di quell'autore o di quel personaggio
che ci rimarrà sempre in mente legato a
quella storia quel libro un po come quel
dolcetto che abbiamo assaggiato da
piccoli e siamo sicuri super sicuri che
un giorno riusciremo a ritrovare quello
stesso sapore
allo stesso modo andiamo in cerca di una
sensazione bella di un libro che ci è
piaciuto
diceva forrest gump che la vita è come
una scatola di cioccolatini non sai mai
quello che ti capita e anche per i libri
e così
noi cerchiamo il libro che ci piace e
leggiamo la recinzione
abbiamo l'autore in televisione
ascoltiamo per radio ci fidiamo del
passaparola di un amico dell'editore
dell'autore che conosciamo però alla
fine siamo noi i giudici il gusto il
nostro le papille gustative sono le
nostre e siamo nè dire se quel libro è
buono o non è buono proprio con un
cioccolatino e anche per le ragazze così
anzi i ragazzi sono i giudici più severi
e quindi se un libro a loro piace vuol
dire che veramente è una buona ricetta
il fatto di leggere insieme per i miei
ragazzi è stato significativo da tanti
punti di vista
uno di questi è il pensiero che la
lettura non dovesse essere più
un'attività solitaria
un'attività da svolgere
al di là della comunità dei ragazzi la
lettura ad alta voce li ha riportati un
po a quella lettura che poi la tipica
dell'antichità perché la lettura
silenziosa un'acquisizione dell'età
moderna nel mondo antico si leggeva
assolutamente sempre ad alta voce la
lettura è un'attività di circolo e per
il mio alunno è stata la stessa cosa
hanno imparato a condividere questo
momento così come condividevano altri
momenti quello del ballo quello della
musica quello della chiacchierata quello
dell'uscita
dal punto di vista didattico li ha
aiutati a lavorare molto sul lessico
interrogarsi sul significato delle
parole
leggere ad alta voce aiuta perché
e come imparare qualcosa meglio la si
legge elia si ascolta contemporaneamente
quindi si raddoppia l'effetto
è inoltre aiuta a superare delle
timidezze aiuta a parlare in pubblico e
ad essere più espressivi
e anche un esercizio di concentrazione
si aiuta a migliorare il metodo di
studio e la timidezza e poi una
soddisfazione è stata che alcuni ragazzi
come ad esempio ogni alunno gigi
iazzetta è diventato lettore ufficiali
ad alta voce nella famiglia o per la
fidanzata
in conclusione io credo che l'ora di
lettura dovrebbe essere inserita nei
programmi scolastici di ogni ordine e
grado dall'infanzia fino alle superiori
non come attività a margine come
attività extracurricolare come progetto
no dovrebbe essere inserita nel monte
ore curricolare avere un suo spazio e
non sono stato in pista ben precisi
perché se vogliamo che i ragazzi
diventino lettori dobbiamo insegnare a
diventare dei lettori
e d'altra parte come dice sempre alessia
cimino una mia lunga di prima di
nessuno nasce imparato professore grazie
[Applauso]